it's not often in UK EU relations that
optimism wins the day so this was a rare
moment a smile that said a deal had been
done today's agreement
delivers smooth flowing trade within the
whole United Kingdom protects the
northern Ireland's place in our Union
and Safeguard sovereignty for the people
of Northern Ireland the eu's chief
executive hailed a new honesty in the
relationship and spoke of her pride in
the so named Windsor framework updating
the original Northern Ireland protocol
that governs post-brexit trade between
the UK and the EU this new framework
will allow us to begin a new chapter
it provides for long-lasting solutions
that both of us are confident
will work for all people and businesses
in Northern Ireland the deal provides
for smoother trade between the UK
Mainland and Northern Ireland
eliminating most checks on basic
foodstuffs plants and medicines it's
said to safeguard The Good Friday peace
agreement while upholding the
sovereignty of Northern Ireland allowing
its devolved assembly of veto over
future rules decided by Brussels a
so-called Stormont break but no deal can
overcome the fundamental brexit
contradiction that Northern Ireland
remains in both the UK and the eu's
single market for goods and so the role
of EU law though diminished won't
disappear entirely that may be a deal
breaker for Northern Ireland's
Democratic unionists and the hardcore of
pro-brexit MPS in the conservative party
both of whom the Prime Minister appealed
to when he addressed Parliament later it
does what many said could not be done
removing thousands of pages of EU laws
and making permanent legally binding
changes to the protocol treaty itself
the Prime Minister has confirmed that a
vote will take place inside the House of
Commons before this new deal can become
UK law there's no chance of losing it
he's already been promised the support
of the opposition labor party what Mr
sunac will hope to avoid however is for
yet another New Divide to form inside
the conservative party over brexit
brexit was supposed to have been done at
the end of 2020. in truth it was never
going to be done until the problem of
Northern Ireland was done the UK and EU
leaders are hoping it finally has been
Jonah Al Jazeera London